Joe Biden is facing a lot of criticism
because the president refuses to go to
East Palestine Ohio he was finally asked
about this on ABC News and the president
said not only is he not going to go to
East Palestine he doesn't even really
remember who he's talked to over there
do you have any plan to travel to Ohio
and have you talked with the mayor yet
within two hours
of that derailment the EPA was in there
within two hours every major agency in
the United States government that had
anything to do with Rail and or cleanup
was there and is there so do you plan to
travel there and have you talked with
the mayor I I can't recall that I don't
think I've talked to the mayor I talked
to everyone else there multiple times
talked to both the Senators but both
Governors I've talked to everyone there
to talk to and we made it clear that
everything is available yeah but are you
going to go Mr President hello Mr
President you're gonna answer it you're
not gonna answer because the answer is
no